from the farthest reaches of outer space
to the freezing Tundra of the Antarctic
the Alien series has gone to some truly
wild places but if you're having trouble
keeping track of all the Xenomorphs
synthetics and Engineers let this be
your guide the alien franchise doesn't
typically take place in the present or
even on Earth instead the original alien
takes place in the year 2122 the crew
members of the uscss Nostromo live in a
universe where the Earth is dying due to
human interference hence the Weyland
yutani corporation's desire to build
better Worlds the sequel aliens is set
over 50 years later in 2179 after Ellen
Ripley wakes up from her accidentally
extended cryosleep the third in the
series Alien 3 is set almost immediately
afterward after that the timeline begins
to get a bit tricky the next installment
of the original Anthology Alien
Resurrection Stars a half alien clone of
Ripley and takes place in 2381 over 200
years after alien 3. that's where the
timeline ends at least for now from
there Ridley Scott's controversial
prequel films Prometheus and alien cover
Covenant take place primarily in the
Years 2093 and 2104 respectively just a
few decades before the original alien
between the original series and its
prequels two crossover films were
released that Blended aliens with The
Predator movies AVP Alien vs Predator
was released in 2004 and takes place
that same year its follow-up 2007's
Aliens vs Predator Requiem takes place
immediately after the first AVP needless
to say the alien timeline is all over
the place throughout the alien franchise
we see a handful of different
extraterrestrial creatures from the
original eggs in their face-hugging
offspring to the chest bursters that
grow into full-on Xenomorphs the life
cycle of an alien is a fascinating thing
as it turns out though there are plenty
of other alien variants out there some
of them are even deadlier than the
classic version from 1979. even if the
first alien is the most iconic you still
don't understand what you're dealing
with
perfect organism everyone who's seen
aliens knows and loves the xenomorph
Queen but there are even more variations
than that in Alien 3 a Facehugger uses a
dog or an ox as a host resulting in a
four-legged xenomorph called a runner
this creature is understandably a bit
more Primal than the traditional
two-legged xenomorph as a result it
hunts down the prisoners of fiorina 161
before Ripley and her new companions are
able to take it out this becomes a
recurring Trend throughout the alien
sequels as new variants of the iconic
xenomorph begin to develop by the time
alien Covenant rolls around it's
explained that many of these variations
are due to genetic manipulation by the
Android David who may be the one
responsible for creating the aliens in
the first place by mixing a black liquid
mutagen with different hosts and Gene
pools David creates the genetic template
for what would become known as the
xenomorph from there the alien franchise
is born and the horror continues in the
first alien Nostromo crew member Kane is
infected by a Facehugger while exploring
a down spacecraft on the moon of lv426
immediately following his exposure he's
taken back aboard the Nostromo ignoring
Ripley's very logical quarantine
protocols and operated on by the Android
hash eventually the Facehugger detaches
itself and dies and Kane wakes up
seemingly back to normal except nothing
would ever be normal again in a shocking
moment that audience members in 1979
certainly didn't see coming the chest
burster brutally tears its way out of
Kane's rib cage the tiny alien gets away
and it only takes a few hours before
it's a full-fledged xenomorph but how
does it grow up so fast the exact
lifespan and life cycle of the titular
alien creatures is something of a
mystery what we do know is that
immediately upon the chessburster's
birth it hides in a dark and isolated
area to undergo its metamorphosis does
it grow
yeah
very rapidly by the time the creature is
next seen on the Nostromo its
transformation is complete the
adult-sized Alien Drone is Now smarter
scarier and far deadlier if the
xenomorph is anything like life on Earth
then its quick Evolution might be the
Catalyst for its murderous Rampage after
all such a fast transformation would
require a whole lot of calories
extraterrestrials aren't the only Sci-Fi
beings to regularly show up in the alien
movies no matter the installment aside
from the Alien vs Predator spin-offs a
synthetic Android manages to rear its
human-like head and cause some commotion
sometimes they're good sometimes they're
bad but more often than not they're
integral to the plot and have some sort
of hidden agenda in the original alien
the Android Ash is an A2 model synthetic
pretending to be human and he's
programmed to capture the xenomorph
alive even if that means killing his
crewmates future sequels include a
variety of synthetics with different
capabilities Bishop is heroic Carl is
more emotionally Advanced and David does
all sorts of Fantastical things Ash on
the other hand didn't have much of a
personality or any personal investment
Beyond his orders from Weyland yutani
more than that Ash was also defective
like the other synthetics in his batch
he was prone to malfunction was it an
older model yeah the hyperdine system's
128.2 well that explains it and the u2s
always were a bit Twitchy evidently the
bugs in ashes model were dealt with in
future models thankfully for Ripley
Bishop reveals that the synthetics made
after the a2s have been fitted with
behavioral inhibitor chips meaning that
they probably won't try to kill you with
a magazine aliens didn't just add more
Xenomorphs to the mix it also introduced
audiences to the rough and rowdy crew of
the USS solaco one of the most beloved
members of this crew is the Android
Bishop who's played by the legendary
actor Lance Henriksen despite Ripley's
unfortunate experiences with the
synthetic on the Nostromo Bishop proves
himself to be nothing short of heroic
throughout the film if it wasn't for him
then Ripley Corporal Hicks and Newt
almost definitely wouldn't have made it
out alive this doesn't last as Hicks and
Newt are killed off in the opening
minutes of alien 3. Bishop survives to
help Ripley one final time before being
deactivated for good but another
Bishop's takes his place this version
designated Bishop 2 in the credits isn't
the heroic Android from Aliens he's here
to capture Ripley in her alien spawn the
company sent me here to show you a
friendly face
to demonstrate how important you are to
us
to me to this day it's unclear if this
bishop is actually human or yet another
Android Henriksen told IGN they were
leaving that open because they weren't
sure what they were going to do with me
but what I saw was that it was a more
advanced model certainly that's not the
only Bishop duplicate out there though
in the original AVP Alien vs Predator
Henriksen returns as a human being named
Charles Bishop Weyland one of the
original founders of Whalen yutani back
in the 21st century there's no ambiguity
here though we can see quite clearly
that this bishop is made of flesh and
blood when he's brutalized by a predator
apparently Bishops can never seem to
catch a break
four decades fans have debated over
which alien movie is the greatest is it
Ridley Scott's original or is it James
Cameron sequel while we couldn't
possibly answer that impossible question
it's clear that David Fincher's Alien 3
is not the franchise's best even though
Ripley Hicks Newt and Bishop all
survived the brutal Invasion at the end
of aliens their Victory is short-lived
as their vessel crashes into the prison
world of fiorina 161 in the third film's
opening this course correction is caused
by a Facehugger which reportedly melted
some of the ship's primary systems Hicks
and Newt are killed in the wreck and
Bishop is left Beyond repair leaving
Ripley to fight off a new xenomorph
without her companions
Edition
how you feeling
my legs hurt while she makes some new
allies on fiorina 161 none are as
meaningful to her as Hicks and Newt
leaving Ripley broken over the loss of
her surrogate family if you hate the
ending to Hick's story as much as
everyone else there are a few unproduced
drafts of Alien 3 out there that keep
Newt Hicks and Bishop in the picture the
2013 video game Aliens colonial Marines
even introduces a parallel history in
which Hicks is saved before his death
it's explained that the body of the
soldier who died in the threequel
belonged to a different Marine who was
forcibly inserted into his pod after
Hicks was awakened while the canonicity
and quality of the colonial Marines is
debatable it certainly gives Hicks a
more heroic send-off on the subject of
the controversial Alien 3 one of the
most confusing moments is the
introduction of the alien egg that ends
up on board the USS solaco of course we
all know that the vase hugger that
hatched from this egg is responsible for
the deaths of Newton Hicks but how did
it manage to climb aboard the spacecraft
in the first place while there isn't a
direct answer to this question in aliens
or Alien 3 there are a few theories that
might shed some light on this parent
plot hole the first is that the alien
queen may have implanted an egg in the
ship before being launched out of the
airlock but this seems a bit far-fetched
given that the Queen's egg Sac was
destroyed by Ripley even if the queen
had laid an egg within the landing gear
of the shuttle before revealing itself
it still doesn't explain how the egg got
further inside the solaco or anywhere
near the cryosleep pods that house the
three survivors another possible
explanation comes from Aliens colonial
Marines which explains that another ship
sent by Weyland yutani intercepted the
sulaka while Ripley and her friends were
in cryosleep it's then that the Weyland
yutani crew LED in a Facehugger from
their own craft where they'd been
experimenting on Xenomorphs which leads
directly into the events of alien 3. one
of the most hated films in the alien
chronology Alien Resurrection takes the
Ripley Saga a step further with cloning
technology genetic experiments result in
the creation of Ripley 8 a clone of the
original protagonist who died over 200
years earlier and she's a bit more alien
than she might care to admit throughout
the film Ripley 8 is shown to be more
aggressive sarcastic and considerably
stronger than the original Star of the
franchise you're programmed to be an app
you're the new Apple model they're
putting out
it may seem like the new Ripley's
updated personality came out of nowhere
but there's actually a good reason for
that Ripley 8 as her name suggests is
not the first clone of Ripley to be
developed but she was the most
successful following Waylon yutani's
shutdown Ripley's genetic samples from
the fiorina 161 prison were collected by
the United systems military which
produced seven defective Ripley hybrid
clones before finding success the eighth
time around due to the change in the
original Ripley's DNA during the events
of Alien 3 which include a new Queen
growing inside of her Ripley 8 was grown
from a different genetic template that
includes xenomorph DNA as a result
Ripley 8 received alien attributes as
well as human ones including more
aggressive tendencies in Superior
physical strength in Alien Resurrection
the Ripley clones are created for one
specific purpose to finally create a
perfect alien queen this would provide
the United system's military with the
genetic material necessary to breed
Xenomorphs Built For War while this
doesn't go as planned for the crew of
the USM ariga which is completely wiped
out by the film's end the program itself
succeeds in producing the first living
alien human favorites Ripley 8 is
counted among them given her shared
alien DNA and connection to the hive
mind as well as the cloned alien queen
Itself by the end of the film The Queen
even births a creature called a newborn
that has some human features a perfect
alien human hybrid the newborn kills its
alien mother before bonding with Ripley
8 in one of the strangest scenes in the
history of the franchise as it turns out
the newborn sees the cloned Ripley as
its true mother due to their shared DNA
so it kills the queen to protect her
sadly the newborn quickly proves itself
a threat to humanity and synthetics
alike just like its other alien siblings
in the climax of Resurrection Ripley 8
is forced to kill it the Way She Knows
Best by ejecting it out into deep space
all she can do is shed a tear for the
tortured creature which is admittedly
more than any of us can do even more
tragic than that though this is the last
we ever see of Ripley after Alien
Resurrection the alien franchise shifted
into its Alien vs Predator face with
plans for a fifth film falling through
that is until Scott returned with his
2012 prequel Prometheus this was the
first first of two scott-helmed prequel
pictures that take place decades before
the events of his original alien despite
the obvious connections though
Prometheus doesn't exactly commit to
being a prequel instead it features some
inconsistencies that have made some fans
theorize that it might be a sort of
prequel reboot hybrid instead not unlike
the recent Planet of the Apes trilogy
the world visited an alien and Aliens is
designated lv426 and features the
derelict spacecraft that houses the
alien eggs but Prometheus takes place on
a more breathable world called lv223
likewise the downed crafts seen in
Prometheus doesn't house any eggs just
plenty of black goo another change can
be seen in the differences between the
so-called space jockey and alien and the
dead engineer in Prometheus there are
even moments in Alien Covenant that seem
to contradict Cameron's aliens including
the idea that massive hordes of
Xenomorphs could be created Without a
Queen plus the technology of the prequel
film seems much more advanced compared
to the Retro futuristic aesthetic of The
Originals one of the biggest mysteries
in the alien franchise comes from
Prometheus which follows a group of
explorers as they search for the origins
of life in the Universe during their
mission crew member Meredith Vickers is
revealed to be the daughter of Weyland
yutani founder Peter Weyland of course
given her often cold and logical nature
the question of her Humanity has been
asked time and time again including in
the film itself I was wondering
foreign
it's definitely a possibility Vickers
never bleeds during the film and since
she's crushed by the engineers
Juggernaut craft we never learn whether
her blood runs red or white Vickers also
doesn't seem to care much when her
father is killed and the synthetic David
refers to the elderly billionaire as his
father as well while the film leaves
this question unresolved screenwriter
Damon Lindelof was pretty clear when he
stated that Vickers is made of Flesh and
Bone despite having a daughter of his
own peter Whalen made David to be the
son that he never had Lindelof joked to
MTV what better way to piss off your
daughter than to build the male
equivalent of her Prometheus reveals a
pretty intense truth to its characters
all known life in the universe including
Humanity was created by an alien race
called the engineers the film dives into
the philosophical implications of such a
discovery as the Prometheus crew follows
the ancient star map that leads them to
lv223 excuse and we're here because of a
map you two kids found in a cave is that
right
no yeah
on this Moon the crew learns that the
engineers or at least the one they've
encountered hope to wipe out Humanity by
releasing their powerful black goo upon
the planet thankfully Elizabeth Shaw and
her companions are able to prevent the
apocalypse but not without casualties as
for why the engineers turned on their
creation the truth is that we don't know
it's possible that they were frustrated
with the constant war and violence among
humans or maybe they wanted to use the
black goo to make a New World by
starting everything over again either
way Prometheus never explains their
frustrations and its sequel alien
Covenant doesn't do this plotline any
favors either we also don't learn how
the engineer civilization fell before
the events of Prometheus ruins and an
abandoned facility are clearly shown but
we don't know much more than that while
we've never gotten a direct answer in
the films and likely never will alien
Covenant raises the possibility that the
engineers in lv223 were destroyed by
their own creations at the end of
Prometheus David and Shaw embark on a
New Journey to take the fight to the
engineers and discover why they want to
wipe out Humanity with a hopeful ending
it seemed like these two companions
could headline an entire Trilogy
themselves starting a new saga in the
alien Universe when Scots follow-up
alien Covenant was released though all
those hopes and dreams died when we
catch up with David he explains that
Shaw died years prior what he fails to
mention is that he killed the entire
engineer population on planet four which
saw a post calling it genocide because
she turned on him David used Shaw as an
incubator for his biological experiments
both before and after she died
ultimately he created a protozoomorph
that serves as the ultimate Terror of
the film while we don't see much of Shaw
and Covenant Scott's short film The
Crossing takes place in the time between
prequels explaining how Shaw cared for
David and rebuilt his body before he
betrayed her although Shaw never sees
her Mission realized David's endgame is
only beginning as the Android strives to
create the perfect monster with more
questions than answers we can only hope
to learn more in further installments
what do you believe in David
creation the overall alien Canon like
other big sci-fi franchises is always up
for debate even though AVP Alien vs
Predator and Aliens vs Predator Requiem
came out long before Scott's prequels
they were quickly red gone following the
release of Prometheus while Mainline
Predator installments like Predator 2
have referenced the alien franchise the
world of the Xenomorphs rarely
reciprocates it's exciting to bring
together these Powerhouse franchises but
given the glaring plot holes the AVP
movies no longer fit into the alien lore
one such plot hole is the Revelation
that the Xenomorphs have been on Earth
for centuries and are locked in Eternal
combat with the Predators beyond that
AVP Weyland yutani co-founder Charles
Bishop Weyland contradicts the reveal of
Peter Whalen from Prometheus as does the
hyper-quick development of Xenomorphs
from their human host to fully grown
aliens in a matter of minutes regardless
though the xenomorph Predator battle
sequences are pretty spectacular
ultimately the best way to understand
the AVP films is as their own separate
continuity while the events of AVP fit
in nicely with The Predator franchise
they don't quite work in the expanded
world of alien
foreign